if you're talking to somebody with a  mental illness or who's depressed they  can be super touchy about it so you're  not going to come up to someone and say  hey you should fix your diet they're  just going to be insulted and mad and  saying you know how can you tell me my  symptoms are caused by diet like you  don't understand how hard it is so  that's not the way it goes try and be  compassionate and patient rather than  being angry try to talk to them i mean  if you are mad say you know i'm sorry  you're hurting but it's scaring me as  well  let's try and make a plan and figure out  how we can get through this then you  then they think they're not alone you're  on their team instead of against them  and then start researching and look into  lifestyle look into diet so if you can  lead them to areas of the internet where  there are doctors talking about how to  use low carb or a carnivore diet for  mental health start watching those  videos